so tom cruise
who is famous for you know not doing a
lot of interviews but when he does
interviews tom cruise has a tendency of
you know not uh holding back you know
whether it was the oprah winfrey one
kyle was talking about when he was
jumping i'm saying i love her
i'm in love i love her on the couch all
this stuff you know acting like a kid
and then he wouldn't be on a couch he's
kind of
but anyways yeah vertically that's a
that's interesting
by the way if you ever said that to his
face he'd be very pissed off
please
have you ever seen him with matt lauer
the interview where they're debating
ritalin and brooke shields and all that
stuff you ever seen that or not let me
tell you
there's a part of him there's a part of
tom i like
a lot he's a fiery dude no it's not the
fiery dude
you know when he says do you know what
ritalin does do you know what these
drugs do yeah have you actually looked
at what these drugs do
uni says matt you need to do your
research no you got to go because you're
the journalist
so there's certain things he takes that
i like what he says
but he had a meltdown couple days ago
and it was recorded and here's what it
sounded like and i think kai
has the recording let's see if he has
the right one we need a visual here for
heaven's sake no they don't have a
visual it's just a record one of the
employees apparently recorded him
losing his mind so let's get a picture
of a modern day tom cruise okay
let's get some visual to it put one we
can use so they don't come back saying
you use the wrong one
pull up the story because he's out there
okay let's hear this
all right here we go yeah you got the
audio
audio making movies right now because of
us because they believe in us and what
we're doing
i'm on the phone with every studio at
night
insurance companies producers
and they're looking at us and using us
to make their movies
we are creating thousands of jobs
i don't ever want to see it again ever
and if you don't do it you're fired and
i see you do it again you're
gone and anyone on this crew does it
that's it and you do and you too
and you if you ever do it again
that's it no apologies
you can tell it to the people that are
losing their own
because our industry is shut down it's
not going to put food on their table
or pay for their college education
that's what i sleep with every night
in the future industry
so i'm sorry i'm beyond your apologies i
have told you
and now i want it and if you don't do it
you're out
we are not shutting this movie down
he's he's not messing around
is it understood if i see it again
you're
going and so are you so you're gonna
cost him his job
and i see it on the set you're going and
you're going
that's it am i clear do you
understand what i want you understand
the responsibility that you have
because i will deal with your reason
it's like the scene from uh tropic
thunder i will
you know what's it i'm talking about
tropic thunder tom show when he when he
plays the uh
when he plays the super agent um patrick
do you think he's requiring the vaccine
so so so when you hear this how do you
prom how do you process it when you hear
this what do you think what was the
infraction
so apparently one of they were a little
too close when they were the editors
they were a little too close it was less
than six feet and he lost it
i gotta agree with tom on this one okay
maybe not in the manner in which he
completely had a freaking meltdown but
understand what he said
i'm the one that this falls on yeah i
gotta deal with the insurance companies
i'm creating thousands of jobs me me me
me me but the reality is if he wasn't so
over the top he actually has a point
here all these people are so you should
have said i'm creating these jobs hey
guys
just please stop six like he should
sound like that if he didn't have that
melt that we would not be talking about
him but this is this is very tom
cruise-ish look
he does have truth to what he's doing
the movie industry has suffered
great i mean if there's okay yes here's
a shout out to gavin newsom here's a
first and last
wow he wants it go for it go for it
he is looking forward to this one he has
employee of the year he has deemed a
studios
in la to be essential and allowed them
to stay open
congratulations okay how's that
how's that food at french laundry by the
way they just got a
3.5 million dollars uh ppp
loan i think they just got it and a big
big loan not not a restaurant no
they just got um his business got 350
his vineyard and i think french laundry
got a massive check as well
what if french laundry just get a check
on go to french laundry pp
uh uh uh 2.4 million dollars one day
restaurant
17 times more than the average
restaurant in the bay area they got 2.4
million dollars
french laundry is what they got so gavin
knew some uh
there are better places to eat so in the
wine valley so here's a question for you
by the way just so you know five of his
staffers quit this morning
tom cruise ward just came out an hour
ago five of the staffers quit this
morning
right before we went live a fabulous
staffer's quote from uh
the the the what do you call it the set
but there's a couple ways i process this
number one way i process this
is this guy's putting his own money on
the line
he's paid all the whatever things he has
to do to make it right he spent 500
thousand dollars of his own money to
make this
he's also the producer yeah he is
mission impossible so he's putting his
own money on the line
so there's a couple ways you probably
some are saying oh some are speculating
saying this was intentional
he said this because he wants to be seen
and heard responsible
you know some are saying he did this
intentional the recording to leak
because
you know he's trying to use it to
promote the movie that's coming out i
don't know about that i don't know
what i will tell you is there's one
thing about tom cruise
the guy loves what he does for a living
and the guy
loves working you're hearing a guy
that is sick of not being able to do his
art and his craft that he loves
just so you know scientology i
interviewed one time a guy named mark
headley once i interviewed that guy i
got
emails from the headquarters of
scientology okay i got
blocked by many scientologists after i
did i just did the interview
and if you watch the interview you would
see me challenging mark headley
on what scientology church did to him so
it's not an interview of
mark said now i'm successful i'm a
millionaire i'm this i'm that i'm like
where did you learn that work ethic from
he says
yeah i guess i know where you're going
with this i probably learned how to work
out from being part of the church of
scientology
i said so where you worked says anywhere
i've worked people have said i've never
met somebody that works with heart
anyways
the moment i touch scientology block
from a bunch of different people that
are scientologists okay
and i got messages you set that aside
with tom cruise
this guy's a stutter and a half he jumps
out of airplanes guys are freaking sick
i mean
he does his own stunts he's a start he's
not a media
you know he's not coming up saying hey
look at me i don't even know if he's got
an instagram account i don't think he's
on twitter
i don't think he cares if you know what
he wears
what he does he doesn't care to show to
the shows he still never won an
oscar one of the best actors of all time
to have never won an
oscar this guy's done he had me at home
you know you know you had me at hello he
did jerry maguire which he crushed it
he did your top gun risky business
forget about those movies he did a few
good men he did the rain man and when he
did rain man dustin hoffman won
so many of the people that did movies
with him want but this guy's never wants
something he's
he's going to be like he's going to
[ __ ] kidding me he's going to get a
lifetime achievement
that's that's pathetic the guy is a
brilliant guy
60 yet how old is he kion he's got it
he's late
you're also guessing that he's more in
shape than anybody else in here
in his late fifties okay here's what
looks great
he looks great you know stressed out
though no doubt about it he's stressed
out
but that's a stressed out of a person to
me but what was he saying to go back to
your life
possible be responsible i'm on the phone
with insurance companies at night
so you're saying ceos should not require
vaccines and yet they're talking to
their insurance companies about bringing
their workers back into the office
yeah but he lost five staffers so
meaning there's a risk for whatever
position you take he's
the point i'm trying to make you is
everybody he's gonna replace them in
five minutes but
i know he's gonna replace him in five
minutes it's the annoying phase of
trying to replace somebody that's doing
the job that you got to go and say put
it out there find somebody
wait a week qualifying background check
two week notice
it's not easy i hear you it's time it's
the three weeks that you don't want to
take with the set people being there
right so
but here's here's where i'm going with
this part here's where i'm going with
this part look who
ended up seeing like the dick here the
[ __ ] here
who tom cruise is the [ __ ] he's the
ceo
the ceo of the project ended up being
the [ __ ]
because he's trying to do what's
responsible and still the world
is saying what a freaking [ __ ] you
know what a freaking [ __ ] this guy is
and he doesn't care about this thing
doesn't care about that
you don't think he has pressure that no
one knows about you think he's you think
the pressure he has is money pressure
do you think he wakes up in the morning
so i got to pay my bills do you think
it's that pressure
well i think it's the pressure of let me
do my work and my art and go back to
being one of the guys
please be responsible for them
people are relying on us to send their
kids to college people are relying on us
to put food on the table
he was i mean i will defend a lot of
what he was saying because he was saying
the industry is using this filming
as a benchmark to see to measure the
efficacy of opening up
filmmaking again in a bigger way where
we are representative of something
bigger
than just this movie he said that he
spoke for
employees sounded like an ambassador he
sounded like a pissed off ambassador
saying we're going to set the tone for
everybody
really creative usage of the f i mean he
can use it in many different ways
grammatically speaking i tell you one
thing if you
ever listened to how we spoke in the
military
you know you would like you would think
we had an obsession with the f-bomb it
was every other word was so
you know that's why they say cussing
like a sailor yeah you know you know you
know
sports military i'm sure you're on the
set you're ticked off i mean you guys
seen christian you ever saw christian
bay loser
you ever seen christian buildings so you
think about the people that have lost it
chris berman lost it once
does anybody here know what after
they're doing does anybody know their
job
you've never seen chris berman lose i
would show it if youtube wouldn't censor
but
you don't know riley bill o'reilly's do
it live
let's do it live oh god you've never
seen glenn beck losing
hazelnut okay yes you're right
karen you we should do this you all you
rich people
shut up you've never seen that oh my
gosh did you see
one of them you guys are already like
cutting did you
the rick santelli thing cnbc
oh yeah yeah i saw rick that was wait
wait wait
he says there has to be a better way
than this there has to be
and then the last guesses so how's that
working out for you
how's that working out for you rick but
i you know what i respect
him for being able to push the envelope
with his own co-workers this all reminds
me of this every single meltdown
speaking of tom cruise tell us i want
the truth
yeah i want the truth and he doesn't
have enough and he doesn't have an
oscar reminds me of how do you not have
an answer
dude i've been looking for that for 42
years i want the truth as well so
it's been a lifelong mission lifelong
mission okay so is that is that enough
to get tom cruise out of our system is
that the time i'm
you know watch i think it's mario that's
shutting down the today's zombie yeah
mario was here early this morning mary's
about to walk in he's about to walk in
with a ccp
shirt on
we have our pitch stories danielle was
on i was on zoom yesterday you walked
out of the meeting i'm left with eric
and kai
and mario all right guys let's wrap up
what stories want to do i go hey i think
we should cover this tom cruise story
it's pretty big
mario's like no i don't think that i
think maybe that's a different something
i go latter you know like i think it's a
pretty big story i think people are
going to be interested in it
it's tom cruise i don't know we're going
back and forth you you cannot have it
you can't you cannot have a female in
the room who
pauses the volleyball scene in top gun
and say tom cruise and not talk about it
i'm sorry you just you gotta you gotta
go there okay
is he a top 10 best looking male actor
of all time
would you put him in as a top ten daniel
he looks like he's in your probably yes
yes don't say no danielle not to my
tommy boy
well is it the top ten let me put it
this way the fact that he's a badass
makes him more attractive than he
actually is
i so agree with you i so agree with you
yeah i think he's about us look i i give
him a pass on this one
because i think of him as a ceo
frustrated annoyed trying to do the
responsibility
because he was speaking for the
employees who want want to work in this
country i respect he's a capitalist good
for him
so no negative from me about tom's here
captain story
tom cruise on mario you don't want to do
the tom cruise story [ __ ] it we won't do
it
all right we'll do this hello sorry
danielle family friendly show here
yes oh this is a few her four kids watch
this show what are you doing so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye